hello there you are watching the press
preview it's a first look at what is on
the front pages as they arrive and in
the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shabby and also
the former aide to boris johnson and
broadcaster
colvir ranger very good evening to both
of you
we're going to start by looking at is
what is actually on
those front pages and i'll give you
three guesses
there is only one big story in town
tomorrow and that's the historic england
versus italy
euro 2020 final
the sunday people bring the lions to
life
calling at the team the pride of england
the sunday mirror features a heroic
picture of england's captain harry kane
and some of the team's star players
as well the sunday express goes with the
queen's heartfelt
message to the england manager gareth
southgate
the daily star turns kane into a roman
gladiator in anticipation of an italian
conquest and the telegraph also quotes
the queen
next to a picture of an elated captain
harry kane the observer pictures a cool
and confident south gate
at england's last training session
whilst also flagging public concerns
over the prime minister's plans for
covid
freedom day july the 19th well tonight
we are joined by rachel shabby and
colvir ranger uh hello again to you too
i jolly well hope that you're both into
your football cause there's a lot of it
to talk about tonight isn't there
we're gonna we're gonna start aren't we
with uh the front page
of the sunday mirror there we can
be heroes very simple headline on the
front there
selection of the three lions on the
front
of course fronted by skipper
harry kane rachel
yeah i mean it's not the best pun i've
ever seen on the front of any
fair enough no details i i think
obviously
all the newspapers are focusing on this
and it would be hard not to
there's uh obviously it's been really
lovely actually just to see
the last few days um the mood
in in england and everybody just um
having something to feel cheerful about
has been
just really lovely to behold and i think
there's something about
this team in particular i don't want to
airbrush it
i mean i think there has been um some
unsavory elements to it as well
uh some of the denmark fans uh received
some
pretty nasty verbal abuse in the match
last week
uh a lot of the team players have
received some eye-watering
racist abuse on social media so it's not
all perfect
but there is something about this team
that have made people want to support
them there's something about the way
they show up
the inclusivity they champion uh
the the way that they stand up for
things that matter
social justice uh standing up against
racism taking the knee
uh in that fight against racism um and
supporting causes in the country there's
a sense
that they have created a team
that lots of different kinds of people
want
to support and that is uh quite
different
and quite heartwarming as well and
culver it's nice isn't it to see raheem
sterling
on the front page of this newspaper
because there's a lot of people who say
that given
his contribution to the performance of
this team he often gets overlooked
yeah there has been some talk about that
and sometimes quite rightly so but
but firstly let me just say as a
die-hard england fan i hope my blazer is
giving a little bit of
top marks there for the sartorius the
true families who's
suffered through you know my my england
memories go back to
mexico 86 the handball or the hand of
god
as diego maradona wanted to call it
which knocked us out and the amazing
amounts of
suffering and travesty and bad decisions
that we faced whether it be through
penalties in 1990
or through the years of svengar and
eriksen and fabio cappello when it felt
like
we had a great a good manager but maybe
not for us
um and and now where we have a team
which has actually it's not just been
about this tournament this team has been
worked on by
south uh gareth southgate uh over a
number of years it's been a four-year
process the last world cup which
surprised many of us when england got to
the semi-finals
but he's built something here it's not
been a matter of the last few months
it's been about four years
of forging the right mentality the right
approach the right tactics
success doesn't occur overnight we all
know that in any way shape or form
so there's been a lot of hard work and
that credit must be given
to all those people who've been involved
that the fa the coaches the backroom
staff
and the players themselves who bought
into the the mentality that's got them
to this final whatever happens they've
made history already
as being the first england team to get
to a european championship
final and i'm hoping praying that
they'll make history tomorrow by winning
it for england for the first time but
as rachel says this team has done
something very special because
all teams let's be honest in sport
reflect society in one way or another
and this team has had the challenge of
reflecting a modern british society
a post-brexit british society a society
that's been scarred much as the rest of
the world has been done by kobe
and is looking for something some
something that they could all
come together around and and it felt
like it felt like they have done and
this team has slowly
it hasn't happened that right at the
start in fact there was a lot of
skepticism
about this team about the way it would
compete about its capabilities
about the kind of leaders that it held
but they've dispelled that
by their deeds and actions on the pitch
as well as
how they've behaved off the pitch this
is not a team that's been seen in a
dentist chair or out in bars or
you know doing things that have bought
sort of cast of shadows sometimes over
previous england teams
this is a team that has done as rachel's
also saying
stood up for things they believe in um
showing the causes
they want to fight for and it's been
wonderful to see them grow
not just as a team but as individuals
and hopefully to success tomorrow
you're quite right to point out the way
that they've conducted themselves and
in fact that's been something that her
majesty the queen rachel was keen
to point out when she wrote that letter
to gareth
southgate basically saying to them you
know you've got to the final you've done
jolly well indeed but i really want to
commend you on the way you've conducted
yourselves
yeah and i think that's something
definitely that
um people have just picked up on there's
something about that
that feels authentic in the sense that
you know i can remember the image of
football as being completely different
you know
just bling and flashiness and you know
just very removed from society now
of course these footballers have
lifestyles and salaries that most of us
can
only dream of but there's something
about the way that they show up
and the causes that they support and
just the way they conduct themselves
that makes it
makes it seem like they are very much
still part of society
you know they're they're in this society
um
and i think that is is tangible
um and again it builds up a connection
with people
you can see it in the sort of engagement
they have on social media the kind of
the kind of the language and the way
that they um engage with their fans
as much as the campaigns they
choose to champion you know we can think
of marcus rashford and the free school
meals
their commitment to donating to the nhs
um
taking the knee so all of these things
combined
they it does make it feel like a team
that
you know you they're building support
they're building a very diverse and
inclusive
um form of support and i think that is
quite different and quite new
yeah there's a video i don't know if
you've seen it on youtube where they're
all trying on their suits ahead of the
the team
photo and just the camaraderie amongst
them they've
all got very different accents they've
all got very different backgrounds
but they're all just really good mates
and that's lovely to see
i think it's worth pointing out as well
also in the express here
uh talking about the number of people
who are expected to be pulling a sickie
if england win tomorrow on monday
morning and you think bosses need to be
worried about uh people turning up
well i think there'll be a collective in
uh england
um maybe productivity dick on monday
but both if we win and potentially if we
don't because i think there'll be a lot
of emotion
that will be drained i i know after the
last few matches and most people
watching
it is sometimes a bit gut-wrenching the
highs and the lows of going through
the football match and what can happen
but look
we're all hoping for the win uh i think
if there is a bit of a
a dip on monday there normally is quite
a boost
generally to the country and sometimes
even to productivity and the
gdp when a country does succeed in these
kinds of things i think the french when
they won the world cup in 98 felt it for
a few months afterwards i've been
reading about that previously
in other countries that especially if
you host if you've hosted and although
england hasn't hosted this tournament
it has worked out in a way where uh
nearly all of their matches except one
has been have been played at wembley so
let's hope
if there's a dip on monday there's a
more longer term boost
over the coming months in the summer to
the economy as we all celebrate
hopefully
uh the win in there in fine fashion yeah
you've got to think long term haven't we
okay well
hang tight we'll be back with you
shortly yeah coming up the lions
are of course on the world stage with
england itching
to see if a euro 2020 win really is
coming home welcome back you're watching
the press preview with me again are
rachel shabby and
colvier ranger hello again to you too
it was really nice wasn't it to talk
about football in the first
half of this press preview because it's
nice to have a positive story we've had
you know months and months haven't we of
a lot of difficult
topics to deal with but i need to take
us back there
if if we can uh front page of the
observer talking about
uh 50 of people still
want some kind of restrictions to stay
in place
uh instead of just removing them all for
freedom day on july the 19th and the
other one
that we cannot ignore is the front page
of the sunday telegraph where the new
health secretary
has given his first interview and he's
talking about waiting lists could soar
to 13 million that's about 20
of the population this is troublesome
colbert
it is it is and look it's we're coming
back to the point of how have we been
through covert and at this point
where it appears that the prime minister
tomorrow will be confirming the
announcement
that uh things like wearing of masks and
social distancing
will be removed from the 19th of july
that's expected to be announced tomorrow
there is this question of well how is
that going to be received by the public
because we've been inundated bombarded
with
messages about safety about hand space
space about how we need to stay at home
work from home
and all those rules that have been very
hard
for people to adopt but eventually they
are absorbed into our site here and
we've all we've all listened and done
what we've had to do
but it gets the point that you can't
just flick a switch and expect everybody
to go
back to some kind of normal it will take
time
and it will take people's confidence and
trust in what they're hearing about
why we're now going back especially when
we're hearing messages about
cases going on now we understand that
there does seem to be from the figures
that being shown
a break between case rates and
hospitalizations and hopefully deaths
so that that's the justification for
where we're heading
but i think there's a lot of work to be
done by the government to get the right
messaging across to people to build the
confidence
that when they say these things they can
take them on board
and move back to a position of taking
that sense of freedom and ownership of
how they feel
about going about their daily lives yeah
and they the work
as well for the government is going to
be looking at those waiting lists rachel
rising from already
more than 5 million to possibly 13
million people on an nhs waiting list
well that's right but just to backtrack
for a second um
it's you know we've got cases doubling
every 10 days
and we've got hospital admissions up
by 50 in one week if people are anxious
about the easing of restrictions and it
seems that
half the population does not want that
to happen 73 percent
wants mass wearing uh to continue
according to the observer you can see
why
um i think the rest of the world is
looking in on the uk and its plans
to release all restrictions on the
just not understanding why on earth we'd
want to do that
when infections are rising there isn't
another country in the world
that has eased restrictions while
infections are going
up and when we look at um the hospital
waiting lists which are awful you're
absolutely right at the moment that's
something like 5.3 million
and by this modeling that sajid javid is
quoting it looks
to double we're talking about the same
nhs
there isn't like a separate nhs if
infections rise
then hospitalizations will rise and
people won't be able to get their
their um the necessary care that they
need already we're hearing of hospitals
having to um cancel operations leeds
hospital
said that this week it's had to cancel
cancer
operation surgeries because hospitals
were taken up by covid
patients so it does seem really
perplexing that the government would
choose to do this and it looks like it's
you know throwing vulnerable vulnerable
people under the bus
and also throwing young people who are
not yet vaccinated
under the well